when people ask you what happened here
tell me 104 members
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my episode 1 Q&A just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far and I'll talk about
Comic Con stuff at the end of this the
video schedule is going to be a little
bit weird after Wednesday just because
there's so much stuff that's going to be
dropping between Wednesday and Sunday
but my Game of Thrones video schedule is
not going to change so no worries there
haven't done a Q&A in a while but here
we go number one
Phillip Andrew asks Euron's gift for
Cersei and you included a picture of
Tyrion no I don't think it's going to be
Tyrion it's a really nice theory because
that is something that she definitely
wants but I actually think it's more
likely that it's one of the sand snakes
just because it would be a really easy
way for the show to get rid of some
characters that people were totally
satisfied with that's like the nicest
way of saying that people really hated
the sand snakes but even though Cersei
seems like she's brushed over Tommen's
death and the death of her other
children she still harbors a lot of
resentment for that so it would be very
cathartic for her as well as for
audiences that hated the sand snakes to
see them get their comeuppance for that
next question Louis asks so do you think
that Aria let ed in you're out of the
phrase dungeon or is he still down there
no remember they actually the Lannisters
brought him to Riverrun to try and get
the castle back last season part of the
terms of that was that Ed Muir would get
the castle back but that he would be
loyal to the crown and the Lannisters so
that's why the blackfish was so pissed
off because he felt like Ed Muir was
just turning the castle over to them
next one the Honorable asks why is Lady
Mormon and Lady Alice Karstark able to
rule but not Sansa in Sansa's Ned the
legitimate heir so you're just asking
why as women they're allowed to rule
their households and Sansa is not it's
mostly because they have no male heirs
in their family and John is a male heir
there's a lot of contention about this
because technically he's a bastard so
his claim isn't as strong as a brand who
is a legitimate male heir but a lot of
it just has to do with the rules of
succession in the way it treats women if
John were dead if bran were dead in
Sansa and Arya were the only ones left
alive then
those claim would be the stronger she
would automatically inherit it which is
what Littlefinger is probably thinking
about he's probably hoping that John
dies at some point in this conflict so
that it'll make his job of putting salsa
in soul control will be much easier but
that's the only way that salsa would
automatically inherit Winterfell if
there were no male heirs around next one
Brendon asks do you think the
positioning of Jaime and Cersei when
standing on the painted map could
indicate Circe's death so you're talking
about you know Jaime standing on the
fingers Cersei standing on the neck
portion of the map I talked about this a
little bit a while ago it's a good
theory but I think they're just winking
at that of all the ways that Cersei
could die Jaime becoming the queen
Slayer fulfilling the valonqar prophecy
is still at the top of my list I'm not
giving up on that completely but I don't
think that's something that's going to
happen this season and even though
there's a lot of coincidences in Game of
Thrones when the director when the DP is
setting up shots they're very particular
about the way they frame things where
the actors stand so it is not a
coincidence that Jamie's standing here
in Cersei standing here like they didn't
just show up to set that day and say hey
why don't we just stand here wouldn't
this be funny so the way I'm choosing to
take it is they're just for shadowing
Circe's eventual death but like I said
not till season 8 next one Ash asks
someone explain to me why dragon stone
was empty it's one of the most powerful
and strategically important castles and
everyone in Westeros just left it empty
WTF well I think the reason for that is
because nobody understands it's
important and they think it's just some
rock that you can't grow anything on
there's not a lot of vassals you
wouldn't make a lot of money off of it
Game of Thrones does that thing where
they're like oh that things that you
didn't think was important at all is
probably the most important thing ever
like we now know that there's a
dragonglass mountain even though we knew
there was dragonglass there before in
the war for the dawn it's more valuable
than the Lannisters gold mines you go
back to season 2 season 3 season 4 and
you just hear Stannis complain about how
he feels like he was banished or exiled
to Dragonstone because it seems like the
worst place ever
but speaking of castles I know a lot of
people are asking about storms and so
hopefully that will be mentioned during
the Stormborn episode because I think
there'll be some Baratheon storm lands
stuff as well as Daenerys
born stuff happening at sea next one
though Gavin asks what about the
greyscale arm in the citadel the one
that asks Sam that the queen of dragons
had arrived
I think it's Jorah you are 100% correct
that was definitely Sir Jorah now we
know where he went with Daenerys sent
him away she told him to find a cure
then returned to me but because of the
implications of Sam Wells book it seems
like he might make a beeline for
Dragonstone although it's hard to tell
if he's being locked up in that cell or
if it's more of a hospital situation
where he's just staying there until he
finds the cure
the only reason I didn't talk about it
more in my episode 1 video is just
because the video was already super long
so sometimes I will cut stuff out and
just include it in later videos just to
keep it under 15 minutes but jumping
forward to that dragonglass question
Fatima asks do you think the dragon
glass has something to do with the cure
for greyscale so yeah after reread like
you know zooming in big time and
rereading that page I definitely think
that's what they're implying there's a
lot more that you can't read on this
page here but it talks about ingesting
on the same page where it's talking
about dragonglass so I think that's what
you're meant to take away from that is
that sir Jorah will just make a beeline
for Dragonstone if they don't have
dragon glass at the citadel otherwise I
would say Samwell would just reread that
page and say oh here you go you know
just crush some dragon glass up drink it
down you should be fine in a couple
weeks that's probably going to be one of
my next bonus videos about how dragon
glass is now the ultimate object on Game
of Thrones it is the cause and solution
to the White Walkers like you literally
put a piece of it in someone's heart and
turn them into the night King you stab
them with it again it makes them explode
into a thousand pieces you can cure
greyscale with it you can mix it with
castle-forged steel to create Valyrian
steel which is something that won't be
important till season 8 but we can talk
about that in more videos next question
lost asks are we done with Braavos do we
expect to hear from Jack and/or Daario
again well I don't think that they're
gone forever but I don't think they're
going to be spending any time in the
east this season the red priests are
still a really big deal
their main presence is in the east so
they have to come back at some point
there are a lot of things that the TV
show cuts out I would totally forgive
them not going to the east this season
just because
there's so much stuff happening in
Westeros so many characters have to come
together before the final season so if
they want to put off some of those
characters coming back to season 8 I
think it'll be just fine next question
Khalid asks where is ghost well he's
just fine they probably just don't want
to spend the money on CG for him in this
episode just assume he's off somewhere
chasing rabbits they said a couple
seasons ago that when they were making
decisions about what big CG creatures to
do they decided to go with the dragons
so the budget that they would be
spending for direwolves is now being
devoted to dragons just because they're
a much bigger deal but the direwolves
are still very important now it seems
like we have another dire wolf showing
up in next week's episode so we can talk
more about them on Sunday next question
say odd ask did anyone else catch
Barrack telling The Hound about the last
time they met at the tournament
foreshadowing tourney at Harrenhal
flashback maybe I think it's totally
possible that could happen maybe later
this season if they're actually going to
do it the tournament that Barrack is
talking about is the attorney of the
hand that we actually saw in the TV show
in season 1 he got unhorsed and then
later was sent by Ned Stark to the
Riverlands to take down the mountain
who've been going crazy it was the first
time he wound up being killed but it was
until after he left but he met the Hound
while he was at the tournament next
one's a big hound one I couldn't find
the person that asked it but I remember
it pretty clearly is it possible that
it's barracks purpose to resurrect the
Hound and not Jon Snow so that's totally
possible they're definitely setting the
Hound up for a big Redemption
in a big hero's arc this season there's
so many things you could take away from
the hounds comments the visions that he
saw in the flames I see a mountain Oh
does that mean the cleganebowl is
confirmed technically no but it would be
a crime for the show to get rid of that
character you're not fooling anybody
with that top knot so it's not
confirmation or anything but part of
barracks purpose could have been to find
and redeem the Hound or bring him to the
point of redemption so that the Hound
could do something great in this big
battle with the night king at the end of
the season so thank you so much for
submitting questions everyone these are
always really fun to do I'll do them for
all the episodes but here's the Comic
Con schedule so what's going to happen
is it's starting Wednesday the videos
will be basically like the big
it's happening at comic-con there's a
game of Thrones panel on Friday I'll do
a video for whatever they do my episode
2 video will post Sunday night just like
normal they'll probably a bonus video
that morning but there'll be a bunch of
trailers for all the comic book stuff
and all the other things that are
dropping this week so if you have
special requests for Comic Con videos
just leave them in the comments below
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner the Dexter please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details it was a new round in this video
I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post Game of Thrones so while you
wait for everything click here for the
episode 2 trailer and you can click here
for my episode 1 video again thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight